arlene foster has been awarded 125 000
pounds in damages after a defamatory
tweet by the tv presenter
dr christian jessen dr jessen tweeted an
unfounded allegation that mrs foster
had been having an extra marital affair
it is a uk record we think in terms of
damages
awarded for defamation by social media
it was december 2019 when these
entirely false allegations began
circulating that arlene foster
was engaged in an extra martial affair
with one of her security detail
and that allegation was tweeted by dr
jessen
despite mrs foster's lawyers advising
him to take it down he didn't do so
for two weeks during which time she
commenced these legal proceedings
she herself told the court that it was
humiliating to have what she described
as the
most important relationship in the world
to her trashed in this way
the dup leader and first minister who's
been married to her husband brian
for 26 years explained how she had to
explain to her two eldest children and
to her 85 year old mother
about these matters just two days before
christmas and she said she didn't think
it was a coincidence that this
tweet had and that allegation had
circulated at a time when she was
involved in efforts to restore
devolved government indeed her lawyer
paul tweed has described this as a very
significant moment indeed
for women in public life
dr jessen has been offered every
opportunity
to do the right thing in this regard
from the outset
but he has pointedly failed to do so
my client is grateful to the court
for this total vindication
which hopefully will also act
as an encouragement and a watershed
for all women in public life who have
been subjected
to similar attacks on social media
in launching his own defense at a very
late stage
dr jessen said he was surprised to learn
that the legal action
had reached an advanced stage he said he
had withdrawn from public life gone to
live with his parents
because he was suffering from mental
illness but the judge said there was no
medical evidence of any nature to
substantiate that claim
and he described dr jessen's claims of
living with his parents and therefore
not receiving the necessary legal
documents
as unsatisfactory and unconvincing the
judge described this
as a highly libelous and grossly
defamatory
tweet before proceeding uh to award the
damages he has 125 thousand pounds
some consolation and vindication perhaps
for mrs foster
on the very day she formally steps down
as the leader of the democratic unionist
party